you dare enter this house
it's a beautiful day to be alive
Wednesday June 7th the day the devil was
buried in [ __ ] sea [ __ ] in the ass
and lit on fire
it's beautiful it's cloudy out so you
have to dig deep to get the beauty of
the [ __ ] clouds you understand me
[ __ ] all that noise uncle Joey here
[ __ ] you what you think I'm doing I'm
[ __ ] busy all right I got time to
[ __ ] dilly-dally on some days but
some days I can rock the house all day
with you [ __ ] you understand me
tonight 7:00 p.m. the Church of what's
happened now tomorrow night Brea are you
[ __ ] nuts or what with his [ __ ]
riffraff all came down to a [ __ ]
start but who gives a [ __ ] about that
the most important thing is today and
now you gonna make the [ __ ] that happen
today some people don't know that some
people taking up a Friday some people
think I'm gonna next sheet listen I
don't give a [ __ ] about nothing I'm
thinking about now I'm gonna put the
pieces together today
Oh who's gonna pay for me waking the
[ __ ] up today that's your attitude every
day who's gonna suck your dick today
when you wake up in the morning that's
the first measure dump all [ __ ] mud
who's gonna [ __ ] pay for me to get
the bed today and bitch-slap all these
[ __ ] Gentiles whoo-hoo
listen you don't [ __ ] around on
Wednesday everybody else is walking
around will box a little half-retarded
I can't wait till Friday who gives a
[ __ ] I'm living for Wednesday [ __ ] you
understand me Wednesdays that you do
you're trying to push ups you write your
goals I got a full day on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] man what do you call that bucket
I got a full day on the [ __ ] bucket
today okay I got a meeting at dad you
get through with 12 I got a call at 1:30
I got a [ __ ] other thing at 3:30 I
got a [ __ ] podcast at 7:00 and I got
a spot that never ends in Neverland
that's what you do I'm working more now
at 54 then when I was a burglary
understand me bein a burglar that was
easy
this [ __ ] I'm doing now this requires
[ __ ] work but Joey
enough with the chitty-chat let's park a
[ __ ] number
it's Wednesday let's let the pigeons
moose oh [ __ ]
this is the weed that krill killed Greg
woman right here he ain't gonna be
playing the piano Maya please know if
this [ __ ] reefer right there but
that's not what important what's
important today is you and that's it and
now you're gonna make it happen we were
hit in the [ __ ] Larry we were the
[ __ ] no-name I don't know what's
wrong with this [ __ ] dog in this pan
he won't stop it's like somebody gave a
blast of [ __ ] coke but what am I
gonna do I gotta [ __ ] be able to get
him saying
look at that wood blowing some [ __ ]
cloud to debt was setting that
[ __ ] herb man free today jack
we ain't got time to dilly-dally
remember the only out one shot at this
[ __ ] light go out there
stab a [ __ ] till they make your
point you understand me
one thing about me is I make my point
that rig day you know why cuz I don't
give a [ __ ]
you gotta break some [ __ ] eggs to make
an omelet people with feelings are gonna
get hurt but it's all about you and if
it ain't you know what the first thing I
do every day is make somebody's [ __ ]
dick Shawn I'm gonna sound selfish you
gotta make somebody's [ __ ] day you
have involve somebody tom you love them
happy birthday whatever the [ __ ] it is
who anybody could type happy birthday on
Facebook we gotta have a [ __ ] lazy
[ __ ] but picking up the phone and
calling him mother [ __ ] saying a dog
I was thinking about you [ __ ] that
Facebook [ __ ] that's a complete
different [ __ ] bag of worms right
there and on top of that you just
worried about you are you gonna make it
today how you gonna [ __ ] eat that is
your family gonna [ __ ] eat don't
worry about Jeff Sessions who gives a
[ __ ] about Jeff Sessions and trunk and
the rest of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're just trying to [ __ ] make it
day to day understand
it's all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] when
you figure out it's all about you
and when your dad met [ __ ] cash do you
think about you you think I don't worry
about 80% of [ __ ] that's on your mind
now when you're in that [ __ ] passage
I say I shouldn't worry about none of
that [ __ ] I should have took it to the
hoop on a [ __ ] Bailey
understand me and that's why I take it
to the dope
I'm a [ __ ] Daly I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] you gotta go for it
every day whatever they tell you that's
good don't tell it to somebody else you
understand you might put that [ __ ]
on Uncle Jack all these [ __ ]
put that pants on one leg at a time
if you don't anything about me I don't
give a [ __ ] about none I don't believe
that I'm not the only persons type I
believe is my own in Europe you go for
it today you grab your dick you salute
the flag you tell these [ __ ]
gonna take a [ __ ] bomb to [ __ ]
stop me Korea's got a light a bomb it's
gotta work it can't be a dud and it's
gonna hit me right in the [ __ ] all
right that's what it takes
listen I went through hell back then we
gave a [ __ ] because I knew at the end of
the day when you own a supermarket
you're there by yourself paying for
you're all [ __ ] groceries and that's
it as that dummy I'm bolted
anyway we'll have a great time in Brea
this weekend but the party stuns
Thursday night Thursday night you come
down you get a little dinner we got a
bag of stars coming with us
wave [ __ ] around Thursday night Lisa
I don't be there Thursday might be a
brave be there or be square
eight o'clock Friday and Saturday we'll
make that [ __ ] town on fire
understand
what do you think should we smoke
another [ __ ] looks [ __ ] yeah it's
Wednesday you can't walk on one leg get
him Sam I missed you guys
you think like I don't do these good I
miss you [ __ ] you're all I got
I rather talk to you [ __ ] in
half these [ __ ] jerk-off walk the
[ __ ] out of my face
these [ __ ] they just talk the
talk and I'll do none
now I'm ready to go I got my notebook
ready I'm gonna get the [ __ ] pen down
the [ __ ] protein powder I don't think
you should know you know I always take a
[ __ ] before you leave the house because
if you don't by the time you get the way
you going when you get now you gotta
take a [ __ ] you gotta take a [ __ ] the
foreign bathroom holy [ __ ] in my own
[ __ ] bathroom you follow me but
anyway that's not here or there that's
not for us to [ __ ] discuss I love you
[ __ ] you guys know I love you
I'm not lead the restaurant we got each
other you know I don't blow smoke up yes
smoke into the [ __ ] screen but that's
it that's that you know I love you
[ __ ] all my heart don't forget
June 24th and 25th I'm over there in
Governors and Long Island for shows and
then I meet me nobody gets their
feelings hurt
JetBlue [ __ ] meant like a doctor row
number two wooden I remember it all
starts on your nutsack it moves the art
it connects with your brain and your
[ __ ] going understand nobody could
tell you nothing get that muscle memory
and tell them all the stuff you did
that's the only [ __ ] muscle memory
you need sup my dick you know why cuz
I'm [ __ ] okay if Joey did do it he's a
fat loser
he went the F felonies his [ __ ]
grandmother and grandfather [ __ ]
second cousins retardation somewhere in
this [ __ ] head if I could put it
together can you imagine what you could
do with a family of my good friends and
people around you that's the other thing
I always had bad [ __ ] French
dog my friends are [ __ ] killers you
understand me I didn't have friends I
had brothers like I said with three
[ __ ] you could take over this
[ __ ] world [ __ ] all these friends
that's after the TV show all you [ __ ]
people start hanging out with seven
people oh my god we look at the [ __ ] out
here I don't have want six people here
with the [ __ ] got to say one time in
the understand
two three people that's all you need
take that to the [ __ ] bank uncle Joey
loves you don't forget Brea Long Island
we got [ __ ] same Louisville Las Vegas
and we got the Borgata July 29 what are
you [ __ ] kidding me or what
anyway I'll see you [ __ ] tonight
seven o'clock be there or be square
remember the other day they're giving
him a model of being a higher stay black